how did you get access to these seniors
now you're going to these retirement
homes what's your pitch to them to let
you come in not just you know as the
program but then eventually with the
cameras it was pretty hard getting
access to these retirement residences
actually because they're usually parts a
part of big chains of retirement
residences so to get to the top person
it's kind of hard we ended up getting
access to two different retirement
residences that let us film there which
was great because when we were in a
retirement residence we were able to you
know give lessons to 40 seniors at a
time and kind of go door-to-door with
our film crew and be able to film them
and I guess the retirement residences
allowed us to do that because they love
the idea of the program the seniors in
their retirement residences we're asking
for computer lessons and then for us to
be able to bring in all these young
people to give the lessons I mean they
loved it yeah i love the opening shot of
the film to where you have like a walker
going to you the corridors and i just
think that's so great because it it just
really sets the tone for the film so
once you met with the seniors how did
you tell them about being on camera and
how how scared were they or actually
encouraged to be you know not only that
they're using the internet but now
they're having this weird machine look
at them with sound equipment and lights
how intimidating was that for them yeah
a lot of them were intimidated by the
camera but they really quickly forgot
about it and it gets really interesting
when you watch reality TV shows you
always wonder how can people act like
that on camera but all the seniors
agreed it's kind of like you put on a
microphone and the cameras there but
then you forget about it cuz you're just
having a conversation with somebody
right um and some of them actually liked
me on camera like sure our main star I
think part of the reason why she got
involved because she wanted to be in a
movie she thought that that was really
cool oh yes she's definitely well
positioned in franchise I really enjoyed
watching her
you